– Hm …
Inge, das schmeckt fantastisch.
Das erinnert mich an Ostern.
– Ostern?
– Ja. In unserer Familie gab es zu Ostern
oft Roulade zum Mittagessen.
– Es gab keinen Hasenbraten?
– Doch, einmal. Da war ich noch sehr klein
und dachte, dass wir den Osterhasen essen.
Ich habe so geweint,
dass meine Eltern seit diesem Tag nie
wieder einen Hasenbraten gemacht haben.
Ostern war für mich als Kind
immer ein tolles Fest.
Meine Eltern
haben überall im Garten bunte Eier
und manchmal auch Schokolade versteckt
und ich musste suchen.
Gab es bei euch zu Ostern auch
bunt gefärbte Eier?
– Natürlich. Aber mein
Lieblingsfest war immer Weihnachten.
– Brachte bei euch der Weihnachtsmann
oder das Christkind die Geschenke?
– Das Christkind.
– Ja, bei uns auch.
– Aber die Geschenke waren
nicht das Wichtigste.
Ich habe mit meinem Mann Günther
immer den Weihnachtsbaum geschmückt.
Wir haben jedes Jahr im Advent
Stollen gegessen
und die Kerzen
am Adventskranz angezündet.
– Das klingt schön.
– Das war schön. Aber allein?
Weihnachten ist kein schönes Fest,
wenn man allein ist.
– Dann lass es uns doch gemeinsam feiern.
Nicht hier … Lass uns wegfahren!
Ein Weihnachtsabenteuer.
– Meinst du das ernst?
– Vollkommen ernst!
– Das wär schön.